uh now our next interview is the longest
serving health secretary or he was when
he handed over to matt hancock in 2018.
that's around 16 months before covert
hit
and when jeremy hunt stepped down from
front bench politics he said he wanted
to do for patient safety what al gore
did for climate change in a new book
he's called for fundamental culture
change in the nhs to prevent avoidable
deaths
and with questions over boris johnson's
future he's never ruled out another run
for the conservative leadership either
let's have a little listen to what
happened when we spoke to jeremy hunt
earlier this week i started by asking
about the nhs
well i think it can be a rogue system
from the point of view of families when
something goes wrong and sometimes they
feel the shutters come down and no one
wants to meet them and explain why a
loved one's died
but i also think it's important to say
that the vast majority of nhs care is
absolutely brilliant i've got three
lovely children all born on the nhs it
mended my elbow last year when i broke
it brilliant surgeon and physio
but the question is when things do go
wrong as they do in all health systems
how good are we at learning from
mistakes and what i found writing this
book is that the one thing the families
want when something goes wrong it's
never money it's just to feel that the
loss of their loved one has some meaning
because the system's learnt from what
what went wrong and
isn't going to make the same mistake
again and i guess that's the critical
point isn't it um not making the same
mistake again do you feel that the
shutters coming down as you say it has
effectively led to more avoidable deaths
yes and
when i was writing this book i came to
realize this is not just a problem in
the nhs it's a problem in healthcare
systems all over the world
but if you think about the most
traumatic thing that could happen in a
hospital which is perhaps a baby dying
that is equally traumatic for the
doctors and nurses and midwives
as it is for the family
and they have to come into work the next
day and and carry on looking after other
patients and they want to do nothing
more than be open and transparent and
learn the lessons
the system can make that impossible they
are worried frankly they'll get fired if
they are open about having made a
mistake but then they are thinking about
you know what are their bosses in the
nhs going to do the regulators what are
they going to say are they going to get
struck off the register
and
the result of that is that the one thing
that matters more than anything else
which is that lessons are learned
is the thing that often doesn't happen
because of this terrible blame culture
and i mean you speak a little bit as if
you
weren't health secretary i mean you were
the longest serving health secretary a
lot of people people would be thinking
why haven't you done something about it
well i try to be honest in this book
about where i did make progress and
where i failed to make progress
i think in terms of transparency and
openness we are in a better place
three million more patients were using
good or outstanding hospitals by the end
of my time compared to when i started
but there were also things i didn't fix
i didn't put in place a long-term plan
for the social care system and
you know when you hear stories as we've
been hearing this week about people
waiting an hour for an ambulance when
they have a stroke
a lot of the reason for that is because
hospitals can't discharge people into
the social care system and they get full
and so
there were things that i wish i had made
more progress on do you think boris
johnson should be making more progress
on social care as well i mean i remember
it's one of the things that he obviously
spoke about when he first became prime
minister and yet it doesn't feel like
much has happened
yes i think he has made some progress
the cap on care cost is being introduced
and that will be a big relief to
people who have
neurological conditions like dementia
but the core funding for local
authorities is still not where it needs
to be you know one of the stories that i
found most shocking recently is the
shrewsbury telford trust which the
report of course found that more than
200 babies and nine mothers died
unnecessarily because of failings in
that trust catastrophic failures in that
trust we also know of course that women
who aren't white are five times more
likely to die during pregnancy
is the maternity care system in the uk
fit for purpose
um the vast majority of births are
totally safe
but we can do better if we had the same
maternity safety rates of sweden a
thousand more babies would live every
year in england and why what's going
wrong is it funding for midwives what
what is it is attitudes well my select
committee did a report into this last
year
and donna ockendon did a report into
shrewsbury and telford
more recently and we both said the same
thing which is number one we need more
midwives and more doctors at least 2 000
more midwives at least 500 more doctors
and nurses and
other people
the government's accepted that
recommendation
the second thing though is have you seen
any progress on that or they just said
that they accept it
not yet what we've heard is the
government accepting the recommendation
but they haven't said when they will
recruit those extra midwives how long
ago was it that you scored for it then
we called for it last summer and
nothing's happened and we need to make
progress urgently because we need
every mum to know that
if they are going into a maternity unit
there isn't going to be a shortage of
midwives or doctors so it is absolutely
essential to act quickly do you think
that if men gave birth a system would
work better
it's a good question um i think there
are
blind spots when it comes to women's
illnesses talking about women's health
um there have been reports of coming
from the u.s that roe vs wade will be
overturned now you've personally said
before that you think the abortion limit
should be reduced to 12 weeks although
you have said that it's not a law that
you would introduce if you would be
prime minister it's just a personal
opinion of yours
what's your reaction to roe vs ways well
i'm totally against it let me
be clear i'm a supporter of the system
in holland
which has
no restrictions on early stage abortions
and then they get progressively
higher as the pregnancy continues so
that's the system that i
but it's a personal view and i
it's a matter of a free vote and i
always said in government positions this
is not something for me to pursue i'd be
extremely worried if in the united
states
we ended up with a situation where women
couldn't access
basic health rights
there's obviously been a huge pressure
on the nhs recently uh through covert
staff absences treatments being delayed
if there is a spike in cases in the
winter are you worried about the
preparedness of the nhs
i'm always worried about the capacity of
the nhs if there was one thing that i
wish i'd known at the start of my quite
a long time as health secretary it is
that you can't solve problems with money
alone money matters but there is a big
and legitimate debate about funding for
the nhs and care system
but you can't put three billion pounds
into the system and expect to see change
unless there are three billion pounds
worth of extra doctors and nurses and
beds to use for many families things are
really really difficult the government
talks about the support that it's
already put her in
but do you feel
that more needs to be done to help those
particular on the lowest incomes
i think the government is doing a lot i
mean the sums of money in terms of
billions of pounds which of course come
from taxpayers ultimately are
huge
but the core problem
is that inflation is at record levels
and that is just eating away at family
finances and and we heard the figures
this week that the inflation rate is
even higher for the poorest families so
i think the heart of the issue is how do
we bring down the inflation rate
personally i'd be very attracted to
things that reduce people's fuel bills
because that helps people on low incomes
but also brings down the inflation rate
and some of your colleagues have talked
about um help on universal credit and
obviously there was a 20 pound uplift
during the pandemic is that the kind of
thing you'd like to see targeted at the
people on lower incomes i wouldn't like
to second guess the chance on the
precise measures but i do think
targeting help is the most important
thing do you like the idea of a windfall
tax
i
let me say this i'm pleased that the
chancellor said all options are on the
table
because i find it very difficult to
justify
bp
buying back two and a half billion
pounds of shares because of a hike in
the oil price do you think it's
inevitable that the government's going
to u-turn on this
i think that we are hearing signs that
all options are on the table and so we
need to watch this space it feels like
it's something that you would be quite
attracted to
personally i find it very difficult to
justify those those extra profits
and the met police have concluded their
investigation into partygate 126 fines
for eight gatherings
should boris johnson have done the same
as kier stamron to pledge to resign uh
if he's found guilty of a criminal
offence
i wouldn't want to minimize uh the anger
people feel about the fact that people
in downing street did not follow the
rules that they set for other people
but i think
that the anger that the electorate feel
the way that my party suffered in the
local elections is about more than that
i think the
fundamental
problems in the economy high inflation
low growth are something that are
worrying a lot of families
i don't think the next election will be
about partygate i think it will be
fought on which party has the best
long-term plans for the economy for
the nhs where i hope my book will make a
contribution at the same time they know
i've spoken to conservative mps who said
that party gay came up an awful lot on
the doorstep at those local elections
because i guess it's about
what people feel is the character of the
prime minister as well
i think there are some voters who were
extremely angry and there were some
conservative voters who were extremely
angry
but i think those same voters also
look at the situation uh in the world
look at what's happening in ukraine
and see that what's going wrong there is
of a scale with a totally different
magnitude
i personally don't believe we should
have a change in prime minister right
now britain has been the most robust
member of the western alliance
and i think the only person who'd be
pleased if we had a
hiatus of several months in the
leadership of the uk would be vladimir
putin that doesn't mean to say that i
don't recognize the anger that a lot of
people feel um do you think there's been
a bit of a complacency
after the local election results because
they were pretty bad for your party
particularly in the south
let me put it this way i think it would
be wrong to say this is just midterm
blues i think the core reasons that
people vote conservative which is
the prospect of strong economic growth
the prospect of lower taxes
these things are not true at the moment
and people are really worried about the
the inflation level the
very low growth rates i'm worried about
it because i want us to be able to fund
the nhs spend more on defense and offer
the prospect of lower taxes and the only
way you can do all those things is by
getting growth into the economy
i'm not going to ask the um
the typical if the ball came loose at
the back of the scrum question because
frankly we actually do know the answer
to it you haven't ruled out another
crack at the leadership and you said
earlier this year that your ambition
hasn't completely vanished
why do you think you would be good at
the top job
it's a very good way of asking the same
question sophie um so full matters for
trying um my i've been very honest that
um i don't rule back a return to
frontline politics my ambition has ebbed
somewhat since stepping back because
i've loved uh
being with my family i know it's a
terrible cliche when politicians say
that but it is actually true in my case
it's not disappeared
it hasn't disappeared but i don't think
now is the moment for a change in prime
minister
for the reason i mentioned i think
something that makes vladimir putin
happy is precisely what we don't want at
this moment when we have the first
european war
in our lifetimes the risk of chemical
and biological and even nuclear weapons
being used
the reports that you send back from
places like mario paul i think do
give us a perspective and britain's role
in the western alliance contrary to what
many people thought has been extremely
important very robust and it's what we
need to see now okay thank you very much
thank you